with your man good are you and Angelo
good oh yeah I mean you know me and Mike
are good yeah me and my sister Wow
haven't got a chance to like actually
like sit down and like talk to her and
forever
we just haven't like caught up how do
you feel watching that clip cuz you were
a little hesitant we first played it
it's always so surreal seeing myself
open up like from the outside looking in
we're on a reality show so show as much
vulnerability as we can so that people
can relate to the things that we're
going through I think like that's really
the purpose of being on a show like that
and I just give it up and give it to God
but it is so awkward and I'm like I'm
gonna cry this season and everything and
I'm not looking forward to seeing the
ugly crappy but I mean a lot of families
deal with family dynamics sister dynamic
what's your relationship right now with
Angela we're in a great space you know I
think a few months ago she was just
settling into becoming a mom and then
trying to get back into work and
balancing all and I know from you know
experience with my daughter that it can
get hard but I was just being a big
sister and being like well hey don't
forget about me over here I need my
sister so that's what that was I think I
was being a little overly sensitive and
but we have a great relationship Angela
I feel like it's not just the distance
between New York and LA that keeps us
apart but I feel like there's emotional
distance a little bit and I think that
that's what's really starting to get to
me you felt like you guys were
emotionally distance is it only because
of motherhood have you guys had a chance
to really talk that through we actually
have you know since the show and yeah it
was motherhood and both of us just
trying to reach for our goals and strive
for our goals you know sometimes in the
date you get so caught up in your
day-to-day you really have to take time
stop and look back and go okay I got a
big time to call you know my family and
make sure everything is okay in seconds
good but do you feel like since she you
know she's a new mom and you like you
said you have a three-year-old do you
feel like you missed those sisterly
bonds that you had prior to motherhood I
definitely do like the pastry days when
we had time to just like run around the
city and we were promoting our sneaker
line like
always together so and we even live
together so definitely miss those times
but you know I'm enjoying us as mothers
now and the maturity and the growth
we've both had it's it's cold like it's
a cool time to go through to like
growing up having our kids grow up
together so it's like a whole new
chapter for us so we have a lot to come
is there anything that you can tease in
a few words of what we can expect this
episode in particular you're gonna see
some real vulnerability like some real
walls broken down you're gonna see the
real me and Angela and dealing with a
family dynamic and it'll be interesting
for you guys okay awkward for me to
watch but interesting for you guys to
see